oh my gosh this is a great question
in that moment i was like yep this could
be it for many years i felt
outside the loop on understanding
let's get started my favorite videos
i've ever worked on are
hey everyone i am sick but i am
dedicated to this q a because i have
gotten
literally thousands of questions from
you and i'm going to answer
not every single one but a lot of them
today let's do this
can i ask you a question
can i ask you a question
we have a delivery
fire cider literally has habanero
peppers
all right oh fire cider
oh well if that doesn't cure me i don't
know what will
what's question number one what are the
top three countries i have visited
ranked by cuisine ooh that's a good
question
um i hate tops because it always means i
have to like
choose the best let me just give some
top three that aren't the top three
taiwan taiwan taiwan street food
is so amazing it is like optimized for
convenience and deliciousness and speed
and one of the things i love about food
is when you order it and then it comes
like moments later and in taiwan that
happens
it's amazing northern italy because i
haven't been to southern italy
so i can't speak for southern italy but
northern italy cuisine
is excellent amazing and very special
number three
northern mexico northern mexico near
tijuana and mexicali
have some of the best tacos on
the earth in my opinion carne asada on
tortillas that are so delicious that is
my favorite
do you ever unplug how do you manage to
take care of your mental well-being as a
journalist
i mean clearly i'm not doing great most
of these people
are not ready to be unplugged i do
unplug
this year i have been unplugging less
because we are
sort of in a sprint in a lot of things
bright trip is sprinting we're building
we're scaling bright trip
we're scaling uh my channel making a lot
of content
so i have not been unplugging and i'm
sort of paying the price hello
darkness in terms of unplugging from the
news
and unplugging from global events i'm
actually quite unplugged a couple years
ago i made a decision
to not be constantly deeply involved in
the news cycle it's one of the best
decisions i made in my life i follow the
news
but i don't follow the daily news i read
the news once a week
and it is the economist and other
publications but i only let it come into
my life
once a week and i'm not following
twitter
i'm not following any feeds apple news
any of that so that is a big
part of my mental well-being is being
informed without having to
feel the constant buzz of of like daily
news
what's the first effect in after effects
that you learned and what made you want
to learn it
oh my gosh this is a great question so
for those of you who don't know
after effects is the animation program
i've used since 2012
to make animations maps and motion
graphics all of it
the first effect that i ever learned in
after effects was
trim paths trim paths is a way of
drawing on a shape
so that it goes from not being there to
drawing on and the first thing i ever
drew on
was this owl
this owl was the first animation i ever
made the owl draws on
and then it drops and it's just my first
animation i've ever did
good job little buddy oh man you got to
start somewhere that was a good question
bless your heart at the bottom so you
need to stir it bless your heart
and i am very well taken care of okay
since iz is clearly here
let's give iz a mic and she's gonna ask
the rest of the questions
look at me sure i'm gonna come to now
what are the top three videos you've
worked on
ever oh man how do i
even answer that question you must
choose
but choose wisely my favorite videos
i've ever worked on
are i think this one i made like a years
ago about why so many people go to
iceland like tourism in iceland
why does everyone come to iceland that
was the first time
that i had gone out not as vox or just
not as anyone as me to make it explainer
and to do it in the field
and it was really fun we were sort of
just going on ice it was for like
this random trip and i just sort of made
this video about why people went to
iceland and there was this one moment
when i'm on this black sand beach in
southern iceland and i was like what if
i drew
the graph on the the black sand with
a drone shot and i just animated over
the drone shot and it was like this like
fun moment and then i did and it just
worked out like
and then i was like we're in the blue
lagoon and there was like no one there
and it was just like it's just the
perfect little thing the explanation
came together really nicely
the second one i would say is when i did
hong kong china for for borders and went
into china
through then we had to wait in the
border and go through this border patrol
scene that took forever and then i made
it to china and i just had this
adventure in china and that was a really
amazing experience for me and it was a
story that i was like
drinking up i just i couldn't get enough
of this story another border season one
episode that was a favorite of mine is
when i went to the island of svalbard
up in north of norway into this island
that's owned by like 90 countries
but it's like controlled by norway i
went on a boat and went to
this this village this russian village
on this island and it's like russia just
has people there just so that they can
say they have people there
and they run this coal mining operation
that loses money but
it doesn't matter it's like that was
such a wild place i was all alone in
this
in this village so those were some of my
favorites those are really good videos
what motivated you to go to therapy did
you have any initial resistance
how has it impacted how you show up as a
partner father and in your relationship
with yourself
wow wow i started going to therapy a
year and a half ago
i was resistant i thought going to
therapy was
a thing that you did for like six weeks
to sort of like get fixed and then
you're better
and i sort of approached it that way
after the first couple of sessions i was
like
so like why did we just talk for those
two sessions like why didn't we like
get to the you know the hard stuff and i
quickly realized that
therapy is actually coaching it's like
it's like having a teacher to teach you
how to develop new skills in your mind
and in your relationships
like playing piano or learning a new
language you have to practice
and usually having a teacher helps you
practice in the right way
over the past year and a half i've
learned a lot about my mind
about my insecurities about my behavior
and where it comes from and how it's
linked to other parts of my life
more importantly i've learned a lot
about patterns patterns in my
relationships
that are just cycles that just happen
and they happen
unconsciously to me but as soon as you
are with a trained professional
talking about your relationship you see
those patterns and you're like oh these
patterns aren't actually
what i want in my relationship and
here's how to change them that's a hard
process it takes a long time
like any new skill but man it is
has changed my life it's changed the way
i think it's changed my relationship
with
is it's changed my relationship with my
boys it's changed my relationship with
my parents
has changed all my relationships and and
of course it has i have new skills that
i didn't have before
i wish therapy was more accessible and
more available
to people than it is in this country at
least i'm glad that
this conversation is normalizing a
little bit more and i'm grateful for
therapy
good question have you ever felt like
your life was in danger
during a visit in a foreign country
yes so in 2010 i was hiking up a volcano
in guatemala with my little brother
and a guy popped out of the bushes with
a gun
and pointed it at my head and that
moment i was like yep
this could be it he just wanted to steal
our stuff
i don't think there was any scenario in
which he would actually pull the trigger
and i'm sure that gun wasn't even loaded
now that i see it now but in that moment
it felt very scary but that was about it
i think
the other the only other one was when i
was driving up these
mountains in nepal on these like
really sketchy roads and there were just
huge drops
left and right yeah that's about it what
is one topic you wish to explore but you
don't think you'll be able to make a
video on
a topic i really want to explore is
climate change
and yet every time i think about it or
every time i hear about it or read about
it there's this sort of
i think there's this collective apathy
that humans have about climate change
because it's so
incredibly invisible until it's not
it's so incredibly slow until it's not
and it's so incredibly widespread the
causes
and and so i am always scheming on like
how can i bring climate change to life
and make it real i don't know how to do
that hopefully someday i'll
crack the code on that but i've been
stumped time and time again on how to
make climate change which is a very real
dooming thing come to life because right
now it's a lot of data
and it's a lot of like squishy like
extreme weather patterns and it's just
like stuff that that
is hard to to really communicate to a
big audience but i'll get there
do you travel with your children if yes
what is their favorite thing about
traveling so much
i do travel with my children we've made
it a point to travel with our children
since the very beginning which is
more complicated and difficult than
traveling not with your children but
incredibly gratifying when we travel the
boys
like to ride bikes we always try to find
bikes
so like we'll bike through amsterdam or
we'll bike through florence or whatever
they love
boats and water and so we always find a
boat so like one of our favorite things
to do is rent a boat and just drive it
through a river or a lake somewhere i
think that it's a common misconception
that like when you travel with kids you
have to
um like do kids stuff all day and yet
we've found a way to travel with our
kids to make it fun to go on a hike like
we went we were in italy before coveted
and we
went up this mountain and it was like
this fun activity this adventure that we
were all on
i was having a blast like made it a fun
thing for the boys too
and that's sort of been our ethos with
travel what does your breakfast look
like today
we need an update to that video for 2021
well i'm making a breakfast update so
for those of you don't know i i made a
video called why i hate american
breakfast i [ __ ] hate american
breakfast
and apparently you all liked it and so
then i made a follow-up about like what
i ate for breakfast
that isn't american breakfast and now
i'm working on a video called
all of the breakfasts that you gave me
like because i got so many suggestions
like turkish breakfast that i am now
trying in my life that i love so my
breakfast now is still a lot of japanese
still a lot of hummus but i'm starting
to branch out and learn what other
breakfasts there are in the world that i
can integrate in my life and i will make
a video about that i promise
before we continue i want to thank
today's sponsor which is policy genius
policy genius is not an insurance
company they are a marketplace where you
can easily compare
life insurance policies life insurance
is something i've started to think about
more
it's something that i think is just wise
for us to have
as people living in this world policy
genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all in one place you can save 50 or more
on life insurance by
comparing quotes on policy genius you
could save
1300 or more per year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies
what i like about policy genius is that
once you
apply the policy genius team handles all
of the
paperwork and scheduling for free
another major thing i love
is that policy genius doesn't sell my
information
to other companies which is a very rare
thing these days and there's no extra
hidden fees anywhere at the process
it's just clear smooth easy transparent
shopping for life insurance i'm thinking
more and more about life insurance as
i'm trying to
become a more responsible adult and i'm
just
it's not something that you think about
very often but it's something that you
can rest
easy at night knowing that you have life
insurance in case some emergency happens
it's for this reason that policy genius
has gotten five-star reviews on
trustpilot and google
they just clearly have really good
service they make applying for this
stuff
easy and very doable so head to
policygenius.com
johnny harris to get started right away
thank you policy genius for sponsoring
this video
back to the questions and now we're back
and i finished my tea
another cup of rosie all right what's
the next question how is your italian
language learning going
no not multibanding that the fact is i
am simultaneously working very hard on
piano
and so i have i memorized my thousand
words
i have been speaking with a local every
week but i'm like i wanted to like start
to do this
and start to like really fly but i feel
like i'm not i'm not there yet i'm
chipping away
and i can understand it and we're
watching a documentary and there was a
bunch of italian i was like
i understand this well you understand
everything except capisce
but man i want to be so fluent in that
language we're thinking about doing
these videos where it's like
30 days of jazz piano 30 days of italian
language
30 days of swimming every day like
whatever it is that johnny's just like
i want more of that in my life so
we'd love suggestions on on what would
be interesting too
do we have a plan of maps evolving into
wallpapers or wall hangings as
johnny harris merch whoa the answer to
that is yes
i'm actually working on a map right now
uh that is a physical printed map that i
will be
dropping at some point in coming weeks
and months
and there won't be many it's like a
special one once a year right
something like that like i'm pouring it
a lot into this map
and so it's like i'm not gonna do one of
these every month like i'm gonna do one
of these a year it's gonna be special
it's gonna be a beautiful paper it's
gonna be everything i love about maps
on a map that is printed so thanks for
reading my mind
stay tuned for my printed map favorite
natural sight on each continent you've
been to
oh natural okay um natural sight
grand canyon in north america or zion
honestly zion
for europe uh the alpujarras the
mountains in spain
that are very beautiful lots of white
villages for switzerland
it is the young frau valley in
in asia it is the
i mean the mountains outside taipei are
just
beautiful or southern india and then for
south america i would say a little
village called via rica
in peru uh the continent of africa i
would say
the the western most point of africa
which is
in senegal there's just immense beauty
on the coastline
there and then i've been to oceania or
australia
and i have not been to antarctica what
are some long-term goals you would like
to achieve with bright trip
i mean bright trip which is the company
that we started a year and a half ago
is basically what i do on this channel
but like applied to
a ton of people making that type of work
and doing it for travel
so it's like if you're going on a trip
to senegal or you're going on a trip
to japan you can watch
an explainer course that gives you the
in-depth
version of like how to do that place and
how to understand its story
i want tons of people to be able to make
this sort of content and my dream is to
have
hundreds of courses that aren't made by
me but are made by like other people
about their experiences
and their knowledge so that's what we're
building that's bright trip right
trip.com
what have you learned about yourself as
you've grown your channel
oh man i have learned huge things about
myself in the past year
number one is i just like telling
stories
i'm the storyteller and my stories must
be told
i just am the guy who wants to just sit
down and write and animate
and look at cuts and play with music
like i am not grand strategist when it
comes to
building the business and iz really is
that person
she knows how to think about building
and growing and strategizing she's the
reason i've hired everyone i've hired we
now have a team of
like eight people working on the channel
and like that's all because of is
if it were just me i would still be
making all the videos
start to finish myself and i would be uh
not growing a business and so i've
learned that i love to tell stories i
will always be a part of that
i don't want anything to do with the
business side of it um as long as i can
keep telling stories
how did you find your videography
aesthetic and
and include animation in there like why
it comes from a lot of influences number
one was just
my own interest in visuals as a kid i
always would film things
and bring it up on the vcr and like look
at what i filmed and like
sort of enjoy looking at it and the art
of it i think maps became a huge
part of my life just as a teenager i
always looked at maps and i think that
paper map feel made its way into my
style
paper maps i think that the
growth of informal filmmaking with the
5d mark
ii back in like 2008
to like casey neistat who really made
his work look almost accidental and
diy and then i think
the biggest most important one as it
pertains to this channel
is what i learned at vox specifically
from joss
fong about visual explanation when you
say something
you show it and you show it and the
writing pairs with what the visual is
and like that that seems so simple but
like the way that she taught me and
trained me to to write in that way
absolutely is the foundation of my of my
style and my work and the value of my
work i would say
if i didn't have that training from jaws
i probably would still just be making
sort of abstract beautiful looking
images
and abstract films without like any
explanation and journalism baked into it
so
thank you joss as always how do you keep
up your curiosity
are you afraid of burning out and how do
you combat that
this is a hard one to answer because i
don't know how i keep up my curiosity
i'm just a curious person
you know like i'm just like it'd be like
how do you keep up your love for
chocolate
it's like i don't know i just like
chocolate
smells chocolaty
that's how i feel about curiosity is
like it's just a deep preference of mine
to be informed about the world and to do
what it takes i think that
one important aspect of my curiosity and
my desire to explain things
is that for many years i felt outside
the loop on
understanding and i felt dumb
and and unintelligent because the school
system
sort of told me i was and so i think a
major thing that drives my curiosity is
i
want to make work that is how i wish
someone had explained it to me you know
and so that drives a lot of my of the
work that i do but in terms of my
curiosity i don't know
like why do you like chocolate i don't
know it's like it's a deep part of me
deep part of who i am and yes i'm
always worried that it's like gonna go
away but i don't think it will
what is your favorite item of clothing
that is not the orange jacket
item of clothing i have these shorts
from
2006 when i was a cross-country runner
in high school
they are red and white which is the
color of my
high school team the ashland grizzlies
and
i've had them forever and i just love
them and i think i'll always love them
someone just really landed a hardball
are you happy jesus
oh man it's like point blank deer in the
headlights
headlights you know am i happy
um yes i i mean and
def the definition of happy when you
live with singular experience you don't
know what happy is for other people so i
don't know
i i'm stressed about things i'm worried
about things i
stress about the future of my children's
lives and etc
but overall i am happy with
the life that i have and and that's
mainly because i have
like deep beautiful relationships with
these people around me
that give a lot of meaning to my life i
think the work that i do and the success
that i've had
in this work is a an amplifier of that
happiness but i wouldn't say it's the
core
i wouldn't say that it is the foundation
it is
an amplifier i feel like a lot of
external factors that aren't
relationship-based
can be amplifiers but i'm not sure that
they can be the core because i see
especially on youtube where there's
algorithms and some videos do well and
some don't
if my happiness were founded on on this
work
it would be a roller coaster and it is
sometimes if i find myself
investing too much of my worth into this
is
is a roller coaster and so i try to
invest in
in my relationships and so yeah i would
say i'm happy in a sense
do you have a team helping you make
videos or is it just you
you seem to be able to create content
with exceptional quality in a short time
i have a team and i'm putting together a
special team for years i've been slowly
training
people to think in the way that i think
when it comes to editing and then
they've added their own
personalities into it as well and
together that's created our style
i have a team that helps edit and
animate and more and more
will take on the edits start to finish i
won't be jumping in premiere
nearly as much anymore as i used to or
after effects although in after effects
i still do jump in and like play around
because i
love it i write though the writing is
the bottleneck for me it's the thing
that i
i do and will probably always do to some
degree because it's what i want to say
and how i want to say and i direct i
have a whole
scripting method that i use to direct
the visuals
that kind of goes with this question uh
which is
uh do you do you have the animation and
editing in your mind before the
narration script
yes absolutely so when i'm writing a
video
and this is if you're on patreon i do i
publish all my scripts
and also do behind the scenes on all
this stuff so
patrons thank you patrons i have the
vision of everything
in my head as i'm writing and then
editors and animators who work on my
videos
will add their own interpretation
they'll add their own
version of what i put often it's super
specific so they'll put in what i put
but then other times it's like they it's
open to interpretation and they put in
whatever they feel so it's a balance
there but i absolutely for
certain visuals have a very specific
vision that i write into these scripts
how do you simplify complex stories and
express it with so much ease
was this something built like built in
you or have you worked on it
i've definitely worked on this craft of
explaining complicated things
what you need to know is that when i'm
writing a piece i am
wrestling with the explanation i'm
wrestling with every single word
because i know that when you're watching
it those words are coming by at a
million miles an hour
your brain's either gonna ingest them or
it's not and if it's not you're not
gonna pause and rewind you're just gonna
move on and be like i didn't get that so
i'm thinking
i need to make sure that every word that
comes out of my mouth is worthy of this
person's brain
it will sink in and they'll understand
and so i'll go over it and i'll even
belabor the explanation oh
like and repeat myself sometimes in the
name of understanding
i think it's natural in me because i've
always been someone who wants to teach
and explain
but again i'm very dyslexic and that i
struggled big time in school because of
that
and so i always wish someone would
explain it to me like once i found out
what like a black hole was or
what a cell was i was once i found that
out like i
understood it in like my adulthood i was
like oh it wasn't that complicated like
i spent
20 years of my life feeling like i
couldn't understand anything and it's
because it was words on on a page
and so all i needed was this visual this
visual helps me understand it and this
like really good explanation and so
i think i have built a whole world
out of trying to explain things in a way
i wish someone would explain it to me
that summarizes a lot of my style so
it's very innate in that way but it's
also
wrought from a desire to explain things
in a way that someone can understand
because i hate the feeling of not
understanding i hate that feeling
and that someone's smarter than me and
that they are using their understanding
to brandish that it's like not a good
feeling i feel like there's so much of
that
and it's like let's let everyone just
understand this thing i was going to ask
if you had a pet peeve but
it sounds like we just heard all about
it
thank you all for being here thank you
patrons
thank you policy genius for supporting
this video and i
next time you see me i will be in a
completely different center we have so
many cool videos coming up in june
about really cool stuff and i'm excited
to share them with you but for now i'm
gonna go take a nap
if you had any questions that you didn't
answer
leave them in the comments so we can
answer them next time that's a good good
point
bye everybody now if you'll excuse me
i'm going to hurl